if you hand out right away fill the gap
[Music]
now add your attending
it's got to be like a snake but grab it
strike this bait
into life let's go
speed of life come on now you peri-peri
it he's hearing it she's not just a
victim and I do what I want that her
hands go there that her head takes me to
the grip so cool because she takes me to
the grip I use that black
[Music]
this time she parried this this way so
you had found the first time it went
forever thought the bull agree here
what's our fine describe the other way
you see behind you that she has goes up
other way I'm going to bak kut she
parried the other way
got it bah
sighs Oh sighs oh this your noggin right
this is customer from outside oh she or
noggin
she will not it
this mark you know we're stuck you're
pushing on me right rather than fight
you I just move that's where your
balance push push I move when I go like
this I have to keep contact with
different I keep contact with it then my
body the contact is telling me how far I
can step up because you see I lost
contact
okay so I'm here and my body is telling
me where I need to move okay
can't let it then you're this on the
resource okay use the contact on the arm
to tell you where you need to go so you
never write so cool - move out of the
way you can just think of it that way
so you're careful move out of the way
whew no I'm here push on me push there
either you have to defend yourself right
you can get maybe a kid oh that's it
okay let's go